will Fox News host Steve Ducey is Off
Script again I have to tell you I really
do enjoy these clips these are Clips
where on the Fox News Morning Show Fox
and Friends Steve Ducey not because he's
a hero not because he's now the Arbiter
of Truth not because he's anything other
than a Fox News propagandist who
sometimes just interjects a little
reality into the brains of his co-hosts
for whatever reason Steve Ducey is
making some what in most of the real
world are uncontroversial admissions but
he's making them on Fox News and it's
fascinating to watch the latest one here
is Steve Ducey saying hey you know the
Biden economy actually is good I mean
okay the White House maybe is having a
messaging issue but the Biden economy
really seems to actually be functioning
quite well take a listen to this and
again he's touting the numbers that we
all see this is not
extraordinarily obscure stuff enough and
that you have just touched on the the
problem for the White House and that is
they've got some pretty good numbers
going on right uh the jobs number is
expected to come out a little later on
today it's expected to be about 250 225
000 unemployment is expected to drop
down to 3.6 yesterday there was a
blowout number ADP said that about a
half a million jobs were added in June
the construction sector itself added 97
000 jobs this is this is not Steve Ducey
making stuff up it's just not the place
you would normally hear it in June
that's the biggest increase month over
month in a decade so they've got these
pretty good numbers but the White House
is stuck with a couple of people who are
having a problem selling it because
people don't feel like things are very
good now uh and the clip of course from
our friend decoding Fox News who does
great work uh typically on Twitter now
also on threads you can find her
decoding Fox News on on threads as well
Steve Ducey is doing this a lot and I
don't want to attribute agency
to what might be Randomness this is you
know forget about right wing media but
there is so much scholarship and I've
read so much books that there's uh
Naseem talibs Fooled by Randomness and
Daniel Kahneman has written about this
in general as humans we like to find
patterns and and attribute agency to
phenomena in the world a really long
time ago but when when pre-modern humans
um started to see things move around in
the sky and the sun come up and go down
whatever
it would sometimes be attributed to a
man in the sky or some particular force
with agency rather than uh sort of the
way that uh the the laws of physics are
impacting celestial bodies so we we like
as humans to put agency and meaning and
whatever I can't do that with Steve
Ducey I don't know that what's happening
here is that Steve Ducey has said you
know my network is spreading a lot of
disinformation I'm going to go out there
and be the voice that tells a little bit
of the truth or something like I have no
reason to think that that is what is
going on but Steve Ducey has this habit
of saying things that go against the
talking points of Fox News here's one
other really good example this one's
from about a week and a half ago this
was related to the supposed there was
like a 72-hour period you might remember
where the Republicans became obsessed
with supposed evidence of Biden bribery
it turned out that it's based on tapes
they don't have from a whistleblower who
might not be a whistleblower who they
hadn't spoken to in three years who more
recently we've uncovered has never
actually spoken to Joe Biden so this one
evaporated quickly but here was Steve
Ducey sort of saying yet there really
isn't evidence here it is unclear what
the joint venture is or was uh and if it
was just for Biden corruption then why
did they have other entities like uh
they had they mentioned Hudson and some
other partners as well if it was just to
influence a former vice president which
I don't know if that's illegal uh why
exactly were there so many other moving
parts and what the Republicans don't do
here yet is they don't say uh if any
laws were broken and if anything was
illegal well what they are saying right
it's quite simple they've not actually
said what are the laws that were broken
and what is it that Joe Biden did that
is illegal make of it what you will let
me know in the comments what you do
think what is going on with Steve Ducey
48 million Americans have some hearing
loss so if you or a loved one is
struggling with hearing loss you are
certainly not alone only one in five
people who would benefit from a hearing
aid actually get a hearing aid our
sponsor MD hearing specializes in FDA
registered rechargeable hearing aids at
a fraction of the cost marked up hearing
aids at an in-person Hearing Clinic can
cost up to ten thousand dollars at MD
hearing you'll pay just three hundred
dollars they perform incredibly well I
have a family friend who's tried a
variety of hearing aids she recently
switched to MD hearing couldn't be
happier loves them you take their free
online hearing tests their world-class
team of licensed audiologists will
advise you how to set up your device
your audiologist is there to provide
ongoing support by video call or text
and MD hearing's new model the Neo is
their smallest hearing aid ever no one
will even know it's there simply go to
mdhearing.com use the code Pacman to get
any pair of hearing aids for just a
hundred and fifty dollars each they will
throw in a free charging case the link
is down below